you are very prolific in your with your
film work your writing what's the plan
now what do you what what what what's in
the next couple of years well I've
written yet another book which is called
the future of Truth very wild Furious
storytelling uh but it will be released
in is it is it fiction um no but
um it's much of it is also storytelling
I'm also pursuing a documentary but
let's forget about that because it's a
little bit unclear what is going to
happen next and I have written a
screenplay for a story that's long in me
and I describe it in my Memoirs it's
called bucking
fard and it's a great title a slip of
tongue yeah and it's about twin sisters
um identical twins who spoke in unison
and we have had twins we we know
sometimes they develop their own
secretive
language but these twins unique we have
never seen or heard of anyone else and I
was in very close contact with them they
spoke in unison that's incredible when
when they opened the door and they said
ah please come in and do you want to
have a cup of tea that can be ritualized
and rehearsed but they would answer a
question that they could not expect
Unison and they there was a court case
um some truck driver an
ugly uh purple-faced truck driver had uh
uh an a restraining order against them
and in court they were allowed to uh
testify in the witness stand together oh
my God but it's an iron principle if you
are in court you Conan uh will testify
and then your sibling will testify and
then the next person there was an
exception they spoke in unison because
they they would be terrified and would
unravel and uh and start shouting and so
and and across the courtroom they
shouted to the truck driver he's
lying uh every word he's saying is a lie
he's lying under oath and then
simultaneous ly the Bucking fasted is is
lying so they both make the same mistake
at the same time same slip of tongue in
the same moment even that I need to
reveal that Sona has twins yeah and uh
have you've seen she's s she's shown us
uh video the cameras of them
communicating with each other before
they could really talk yes and they are
having fullon it it's nonsense to us but
you understand it is a full-on they're
having a full conversation I don't
understand a word of it it's fascinating
to watch but it's a separate language
they do not speak in unison and they do
not make up a I said uh hey uh girls I
said I said girls even though they were
um not girls anymore there were in the
early 40s or late 30s I said to them uh
let's go out to a restaurant they and
they whispered to each other making up
at they whispered in
unison and they said are now restaurant
and there are these made us in tuxedos
and so I said now now let's go to a fish
and chip place around the corner they
speaking in unison to each other and
then they said yeah let's do it so when
is this coming out this uh no it's
there's only a screenplay it's not
financed yet it's not shot yet I'll give
you the money but
it's that would be nice but oh you doubt
I have it do you well I have tens of
thousands of
dollars so yeah one should well I I have
started my own Rogue film school as an
antithesis to all the nonsense you learn
in film schools it's okay that you learn
technical things in film school but but
how to write a screenplay I mean it's
it's very Antiquated and very uh very
uninspired what's going on and U in this
uh Rogue film school I I tell young
people aspiring filmmakers you can today
with a technology you have today you can
make a one and a half hour uh
documentary for under
$110,000 and you can make a feature film
that can be shown in big theaters for
under 50,000 and it actually has been
proven we have seen some films in
theater
successfully um that were made on cell
phones yeah and they're very good and
you can edit on your own laptop just
roll up your sleeves and do it that's
incredible because you were I I think
about your the famous story about you is
that you stole your first camera you
didn't have a camera and you stole it
and I actually I love this line from the
book you you say I refuse to think of it
as stealing you said I was exercising a
natural right to put the camera to its
intended
use I thought I thought that is a
fantastic uh
rationalization but also it makes
perfect sense but you had so many limits
and I wonder you know verer Herzog if
you went into a black hole and you
appear today as a young man your early
20s and you have iPhones yes and you
have computers that can uh laptops that
can edit uh how different uh are the
films are they completely different
films or are you telling my films
wouldn't be different no I don't think
so it's it doesn't matter if I shoot it
on Celluloid when I started it was 35 mm
Celluloid very clumsy expensive uh took
a long time to make a film much longer
than today and yet um with the Clear
Vision that I had I've done one film
after the other I've done I I don't know
over 70 films by now and I have
published at least 10 books and I have
acted in at least 20 films and I have
staged operas so it it wouldn't look
different because writing a book whether
you write it on a laptop or in long hand
doesn't make any difference at all right
and um I I would have probably
functioned uh the same
way